so let's talk about outcome-based
product planning as always
we start with this question right which
is always an interesting question right
what do people love about the products
that they love right think about the the
products that always get high praise for
success and and a fantastic experience
right Amazon Netflix Apple whatever
whatever your favorite product is right
if you were to ask
um a relative or a friend what they love
about those products I guarantee you
that none of them would say I love my
iPhone because it was delivered on time
right I like Amazon Prime because it was
delivered on budget right that's not the
reason that's not how it's not how our
customers measure success it's not how
our users measure success our users
measure success in terms of whether or
not their products solve a problem for
them or if their products meet a need
for them right people love their mobile
phones because they make them happy they
keep them connected they bring them
closer allow them to operate their
business from wherever they are among
other many other things right and and
this you know this this is the way
consumers define success
and if this is the way that they define
success this is the way that we should
be defining the success of our products
and services as well did we meet a need
did we solve our problem instead of we
delivered it and we delivered it on time
and we delivered it on budget right
because our customers don't actually
care about that did you actually solve a
real need for me and if we're going to
measure success in a different way then
we have to change actually how we plan
and communicate our work
now the traditional way of planning and
communicating our work has been in a
linear fashion
right in a in a road map or or in a very
uh you know kind of very uh
you know we're going to do this then
we're going to do this and this and that
and and look and there's a time and a
place where linear product planning
right actually makes sense right when
the thing that we're making
is finite we know exactly what it's
going to look like when it's done we
know exactly what components need to go
into it we know how much work it's going
to take to build it and we have a very
very good sense of what people will do
with it once we give it to them in those
situations where there is low risk and
high certainty linear product planning
makes sense and look there was a time
with software where it actually also
made sense and that was when software
came in a box right so if you think back
if you remember back if you were alive
back when software came in a box you'll
remember that that there was you know
the software ended at some point I
worked at a company called America
Online back in the 90s and we would uh
we would publish our software on CDs
and we would have to print 15 million of
those CDs at a time and so there was a
clear end to the software
and there was a clear sense of what the
software had to do when we reached that
endpoint and then we made a series of
assumptions about what our customers
would do with it but at the very least
there was a linear plan there because
there was there was a deadline an
absolute deadline that we had to hit
because we were physically producing
media with the software on it and so to
communicate that
we use this metaphor the roadmap because
the roadmap makes sense
in a low risk High certainty world right
it's it's easier to communicate our
plans in a linear fashion and and the
map is a great metaphor for this kind of
planning we start at Point a we've got a
destination in point B there's a
distance between those there's maybe
some steps along the way and we estimate
how long it's going to it's going to
take us to get from point A to point B
people can understand this and they can
communicate this and this again makes
sense in a world with uh static products
in a world where there's an absolute
deadline and we can't move forward right
but the reality of the software that we
build today
is that it doesn't conform to those qual
those qualities right our world today is
continuous everything is continuous
right
um the the the software that we build
doesn't come in a box it updates
regularly our apps update
continuously websites update
continuously systems we send system
updates all the time and uh and our
businesses are being driven by software
on top of that and this idea that we can
build a a plan that says we're at Point
a and we're going to point B and these
are the steps in between starts to
become very difficult to maintain in a
world where everything is updating
continuously and changing all the time
and frankly the pace
of that
is getting amazingly faster and faster
and faster I'll tell you that in 2015
when Josh seiden and I started out to
write our second book sense and respond
we did some research and at that time
Amazon was publishing code to production
every 11.6 seconds so five times a
minute Amazon was updating the system
today it's every second right Amazon
releases code to production somewhere in
their systems every second 60 times a
minute
and in that world right of 60 times a
minute
it's impossible to celebrate uh every
software release right the deployment of
software becomes a non-event this idea
that we can measure success simply by
the fact that we've shipped something
becomes moot when you can literally ship
something every second now look they're
at the extreme end of things but it's
worth noting that this is possible
right and the idea that we can plan for
this continuous deployment of of updates
and features becomes much more difficult
to maintain if you're planning in a
linear fashion
and that's just the technology side of
things right it actually becomes uh
increasingly more challenging when you
bake in the humans right so there's the
the tech side of things we can now
deploy things very very quickly we can
get ideas into the hands of our users
very quickly
but we've got the human side of things
and human behavior is complex and it's
unpredictable and so we we don't have a
guarantee of what our customers and our
users are actually going to do with the
software that we provide for them right
we assume that they will do certain
things we hope that they will do certain
things but humans do strange things and
we don't know exactly what they're going
to do and then of course the other thing
that happens is that their behavior
emerges through the use of our products
so not only do they rarely do what we
expect them to do but ultimately they
find things they find ways to do things
with our products that we never imagined
right so a product that was designed to
just to connect people around the world
like Facebook is now being used as a
tool to sway elections and to do lots of
other nasty things in the world like
these things just sort of emerge we
don't know what people are going to do
there's so much uncertainty there's so
much continuous change in the world that
just because we plan something at one
point
doesn't mean it's still going to make
sense when we get to that point in the
plan right because by the time we get
there things may have changed in the
world things may have changed in the
behavior of our customers uh there might
be some you know something has changed
but the product that we're working on
with the competition so just because we
made a plan initially by the time we
actually get to executing some of those
steps doesn't mean they actually make
sense to build right and so if we're
looking to increase the agility
of our organization we need to start to
let go of these linear road maps because
they're not agile they're they're rigid
right it's a strong word to say they are
alive but they are like we set
expectations about a date in the in the
future what features we're going to
deploy the ROI uh that we're going to
see from the road maps and we're on the
hook for it right
but what if something new emerges right
a competitive threat a changing human
behavior something along those lines it
becomes really difficult to do
let me uh let me I mean just just to
give you an example of this in 2008 in
October of 2008 I got a new job I got a
new job in New York City and a company
called the ladders the ladders at the
time was a job search engine for people
who were making more than a hundred
thousand dollars a year so it's like an
executive job search engine and it's a
two-sided Marketplace and the way that
that website that business stays healthy
is we maintain a balanced ecosystem of
jobs to job Seekers and we have that
now
I got my job as the Director of user
experience in October of 2008. I don't
know if you remember October of 2008 but
that was a very very bad month for the
economy in the United States
three weeks after I started my job
Lehman Brothers the brokerage firm
melted down and it started off it kicked
off the financial crisis of 2008 and the
market crashed overnight literally
overnight we went from a balanced
ecosystem of jobs and job Seekers
to lots of job Seekers no jobs
right we had a road map we had a plan
right features for the next nine months
that we were going to build what do we
do do we follow the plan did we adjust
course we committed to those features
those dates that Roi
um how do we move that forward right
and with those rigid product planning
ideas the question becomes how can we
respond effectively
right
and the answer is we can't right we
can't be agile we can't inspect and
adapt we can't sense and respond build
measure learn if we're using these
linear rigid planning techniques right
the world is going to throw obstacles at
us challenges surprises and it's going
to break our plans and it's going to
challenge the organizational inertia
behind the hours of work and negotiation
that it took to get to this right so
much time so much effort is made to get
to this approved roadmap
and then the world throws all these
things at us and it's going to be
difficult for us to react if we continue
to commit to this so we're going to move
away from rigid product planning and
we're going to redefine the way that we
plan our work and communicate our work
away from features away from output and
towards outcomes that's going to be our
goal
right so let's talk about what an
outcome-based product plan look like
looks like the first thing we have to do
is we actually have to change the
questions that we're asking if we're
going to build a new way of product
planning excuse me and a new way of
communicating our work we have to change
the questions that we're asking to start
the plan the old question and you know
this question well right what will we
build
right we always ask this question what
are we going to make what are we working
on right what's the feature that we're
going to ship this Sprint that's the old
question right if we're going to shift
to outcome based product planning we
need a new conversation all right the
new conversation is the new question is
what will people be doing differently
if we succeed
right so it's not enough to say
hey we're going to build this right the
real question is if we build the right
feature and we deploy it we did we
design it well we implement it
successfully and people use it and it
meets a need and it solves a problem
what will people be doing differently
right now the fundamental difference
here is that what we build is a question
about output it's about features right
it's about planning features and dates
and deadlines
what will people be doing differently is
a conversation around outcomes outcomes
are measurable changes in human behavior
and in a world where you can deploy
software every second
right the real measure of Success is Not
did you ship the feature it's did you
impact the behavior of your users in a
positive way and how do you know right
what are they doing differently
now that we've built a system for them
to use or a service or our product so if
we're going to start to shift to
managing the outcomes we have to change
the question that we're asking we're
going to stop asking what are we
building
focus on what will people be doing
differently if we succeed the next thing
is we have to change how we view our
work now we are often in a position
particularly if you work in a large
successful company where we take an
inside out approach to product
development right we build we're big
we're successful we know what customers
want we're going to push our ideas out
into the market and people are going to
love it and we're going to assume that
they're going to love it and we're going
to ship it and it's going to be
fantastic but the reality is that we are
not Geniuses delivering magic products
to people who don't know they need them
right the reality is if we're going to
build an outcome-based way of working we
have to become empathetic problem
solvers for our users and then figure
out to discover what Solutions will make
them successful we have to take an
outside in perspective right head out of
the building understand our customers
learn what it is they're trying to
achieve what's getting in their way what
they're doing today how well that's
working for them where there might be an
opportunity for improvement and then
develop solutions for them that will
make them more successful so instead of
pushing these ideas out to them we go
out to them to learn and then bring that
learning inside to change our
perspective on the work that we're doing
right
the third question the third step in
changing our product planning to
outcomes is to change the destination
right our goal isn't to Target features
but our goal is to Target specific
changes in human behavior now a road map
is a marketing tool with your plans for
the coming quarter or year
it never I really like this definition
because it doesn't say that you need to
Market a set of features you can Market
a set of benefits or a set of outcomes
and when we start to think about it that
way this
is what a high-level outcome-based
product plan could look like let's talk
through this uh and let's let's work it
through so this is this is ultimately at
a high level
what can replace your feature-based
roadmap right so we start at the top
we start with a longer term strategic
theme or an objective right what's the
objective that we're trying to achieve
for the next quarter or two quarters
maybe three quarters at most right and
we can have multiple objectives with
different teams assigned to each one
then on on a roughly quarterly basis
we set
goals based on outcomes based on key
results key results in your okrs are
outcomes they're measurable changes in
human behavior what are the behavior
changes that we want to achieve this
quarter maybe it's an acquisition goal
maybe it's a usage metric maybe it's a
retention metric right we're looking for
those behaviors that are important to us
this quarter next quarter Etc but we're
going to commit to those as the goals
for each quarter
we then have a conversation with our
teams with our colleagues to determine
what we might actually build right but
we couch
these ideas in terms in as hypotheses
hypotheses reflect uh the fact that
these are our best guesses
about what we might build to hit these
quarterly key results or these quarterly
outcome goals the nice thing about
hypothesis statements is that they
reflect the uncertainty
of digital product development right
they don't say we are building this it
says we believe we should build this and
if we do a great job we expect to see
this Behavior change which is the key
result goal now the interesting thing is
about visibility to think about
visibility in the short term
you might have decent visibility about
what ideas you think you should work on
what ideas you think will work what will
actually deliver
the key results and the outcomes that
we're trying to achieve and ultimately
the Strategic goal so for the immediate
first quarter you've got a bunch of
ideas the second one a few more ideas
the further out in time you look the
less accurately You can predict what
you're going to be working on remember
continuous change pandemics
socio-political crises changes in
consumer consumption patterns uh
emergent behavior from the systems are
all the things we talked about just a
few minutes ago and that's not even
everything right all those things are
going to impact what you might be
working on in the future and so to
confidently say well here are 10 things
we're going to work on three quarters
from now or four quarters from now is is
massively risky and and frankly you're
lying to yourself under your
organization and so as we look further
into the future we have fewer ideas
about what we might be doing
right and that's perfectly okay because
what we want to then do
is check in periodically
right talk about what we shipped
what we learned how we're trending
towards our key result goals towards our
outcome-based goals
and then decide okay great now what are
we going to do in the next quarter right
and so what we're doing is just in time
planning on a quarterly basis based on
the evidence that we collected in the
last quarter
right now one way to consider the
metaphor I like to use for this is
Imagine like this type of planning is
like uh it's like walking through a fog
right if you've ever walked through a
fog you know that you can see four or
five steps ahead of you but you can't
see 10 steps or 20 steps ahead of you so
you're not going to go running full
steam and just go you know in One
Direction and hope everything works out
really well right because you could hit
a brick wall you could fall off a cliff
right there's a variety of reasons why
you know you're not going to go running
head first into a fog but when you walk
into a fog if you take four or five
small steps let's call that a small
batch
right
all of a sudden you now reveal the next
four or five steps right you can see
into the fog four or five steps further
right and if there's no obstacle in your
way terrific we're going to keep moving
forward in that direction
but if we start to discover that there
are obstacles in our way ahead of us
once we've taken that small batch into
the into the steps into the fog right we
have to Pivot we have to change course
and that's what being agile is all about
it's about changing course based on
evidence and so when we start to plan
with outcomes right the measure of
success again is isn't right did you
build all the things on the roadmap
right it's are we hitting the behavior
change goals that we set for ourselves
and if not what do we need to change in
our planning process in order to do that
and if we work in small batches in this
case quarters right but whatever
whatever small batch makes sense for you
we collect evidence that then informs
with greater certainty right the
planning for the next quarter and the
quarter after that but three four
quarters in the future
still is generally a mystery to all of
us right so let's talk about how to
build this right because I just showed
it to you
let's talk about how to build this kind
of road map together
okay the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to start with a clear
business problem
okay the question is what is the the
thing that's strategically important for
us in the next six months right what are
we trying to solve for so here's an
example of that hypothetical example
right where we built this is from an
online learning service for lawyers
right so we built our online learning
service to help lawyers maintain their
credentials keep their skill sets
current
and we've observed that customers uh
sign up for an account take one of our
courses and then don't come back
right this decreases the benefit of the
product it's expensive for us because we
have to continuously acquire new
customers rather than selling additional
courses to existing ones that's the
business problem that is important to us
in the next three to six months okay so
we start with a clear business problem
right what do you what what are you
going to take on strategically in the
next quarter or two we then take that
business problem and we turn it into a
positive goal if we solve the problem
what does that look like right so if I
solve that problem where lawyers sign up
for my service take one course
and then never come back and take
another course well then I have built an
effective and engaging continuing
education learning product with the
entirety of a lawyer's career to ensure
their skills are current that's my goal
right I want to solve the problem that's
what it looks like if I solve the
problem right what we've done here is
we've written our first objective right
the thing that goes at the top of the
road map this is our strategic goal for
the next three to six months we want to
build an effective and engaging
continuing education learning product
for the entirety of a lawyer's career
which is great
then we come back to our key question
right if we solve the problem if I
achieve that objective right what will
people be doing differently
well
here's some things that would tell me
that if I solve that objective what
people could potentially be doing
differently right each user will take at
least three courses each year
25 percent of new customers will come
from Word of Mouth referrals
and each Law Firm that signs up
registers at least 50 percent of its
staff
now what I've done here is I've defined
My Success criteria in terms of outcomes
or in terms of key results
right every single one of these things
on the screen is a measure of human
behavior
it is an outcome and if I see I've
determined that if if I see these
behaviors right I will have achieved my
objective it means that I have chosen
the right features
I've chosen the right business model
pricing model value proposition code
copy design to achieve these Behavior
changes right and the measure of Success
is Not
what I actually shipped it's did I
actually get these things to happen and
so what we've actually done here
as we've written an okr statement right
our objective
is to build this effective online
learning tool and our key results are at
least these three Behavior changes that
can serve as the destination
for our product planning efforts right
as the quarterly key result goals right
and so these things they end up in that
roadmap
right the the objective
is at the top the key results end up on
a quarterly basis and that becomes what
we're actually targeting
now the next step in the process is for
us to work together as a team
and to brainstorm solution hypotheses
that may achieve those objectives and
those key results and and those outcomes
right those uh because now now we've got
our strategic goal and now we've got our
destination we've got the behavior
changes that we're targeting now we can
talk about what might we build
and as I mentioned before we want to
talk about our work in terms of solution
hypotheses
because there is doubt
right about whether or not these ideas
are actually going to deliver the
behavior change that we're looking for
remember all that uncertainty all that
continuous change that we talked about
at the beginning all those things
threaten the success of your idea so we
write our feature ideas in terms of
hypotheses because
it reflects that uncertainty in the work
right as much as much as we hate to say
it we all know it right software
development is is difficult work it's
complex and it's unpredictable and so
let's reflect that in how we describe
the work that we're going to do this is
the template that we use to write
hypotheses it starts with the words we
believe right because we don't know
right we believe we will increase the
number of classes taken by each customer
by 300 percent right that's my behavior
change my outcome if mid-career lawyers
that's my target audience right feel
like they're progressing ahead of
average rates in their career that's why
they would care about this with a
leaderboard of internal and external
usage statistics right so I'm gonna I'm
going to gamify the learning platform
that's my that's my feature idea
right is it going to work
I don't know
is this a compelling story yeah I think
it is is it a true story I don't know
yet right I believe it is but we're
gonna have to figure out whether
gamification is going to drive these
mid-career lawyers to take three at
least three classes every time they come
to the to the platform right and the
hypotheses that we write become these
quarterly activities as we showed before
right I'm gonna have a lot of those in
the short term fewer as we look further
out over time
once we've got the roadmap planned we
then need to start to assess the risks
in our hypotheses right because we're
not sure we're not confident and so as
we think about our hypotheses we have to
determine what's risky about them and
then design experiments to test those
ideas right what can we do
to learn whether or not these are the
right things to build and as we identify
these uh the hypotheses that we want to
work on
we have to ask two key questions right
the first question is what's the most
important thing we need to learn first
about this hypothesis
right what's the biggest risk about it
and then once we've identified the
biggest risk what's the least amount of
work we need to do to learn that to
understand whether that's a real risk or
not and how we might mitigate it
and the answer to that second question
is your experiment sometimes those are
called MVPs right just want to be clear
that the the the goal here is to drive
experimentation and learning the example
on your screen is from Rotterdam in the
Netherlands right they're always trying
to figure out where to put another
bicycle rack for people to lock their
bicycles now what they could do is they
could just build the bike rack pour
concrete install these metal bike racks
and hope that people use them right they
should ship the feature which is what we
do a lot at work every day right instead
they run these experiments they take
this mobile bike rack it's on wheels
they put it in a destination somewhere
in the city where they think it will be
helpful
they monitor the usage of this
experiment right do people lock their
bikes here how often right how many
people do it how many bikes are locked
to it and if the usage the behavior
change the outcome is sufficient enough
then they invest in making this
permanent
right but if it isn't right if people
don't use it if people don't lock their
bikes here they put them somewhere else
right they will move this to another
location in the city right they will
pivot on this idea they will kill this
idea and they will try something else
and it's a perfect metaphor for the work
that you're doing because again the
measure of success for the city of
Rotterdam is not how many bike racks
they've installed right it's how many
people are using the bike racks
that's the goal right so they have to
figure out the right configuration the
right location and the same thing holds
true for you the measure for your
success is not how many features did we
ship
is did we make our customers more
successful right are they doing things
uh that benefit them and then ultimately
us now
the interesting thing is that look this
isn't this is a just-in-time planning
process and so we need to to put in
check-ins that allow us to reflect to
decide to plan further I use quarterly
as the you know the the delineation in
time here simply because uh a quarter is
less than a year and it works well for a
lot of companies now obviously if a
quarter doesn't make sense in your
business then use a time frame that
makes sense for you but just whatever it
is make sure that it's shorter than what
you're using today
and then we use those quarterly
check-ins with our stakeholders to ask
these questions right how are we
trending towards those key results those
outcomes are we making progress towards
them
um what are we learning along the way
what's working what's not working what
what are experiments teaching us the
hypotheses that we've got planned for
this quarter are they proving true are
they proving false which of those
hypotheses should we keep funding
that's a big question which one should
we stop funding because they're not
working out is there a pivot that we
should make right so maintain your
strategy but change the tactics are
there hypotheses they're just dead
they're not going to work we're going to
kill them and move away from them
um did we learn something new
right and we should add that to our
backlog now for the next quarter or this
quarter or whatever it is right we want
to have these conversations but remember
these quarterly check-ins
they need to be forward-looking
conversations right this is not a review
or an assessment of what the team did in
the last quarter right ideally all of
that is already known it's a
conversation that says what are we going
to do in the next quarter what have you
learned along the way and what are we
doing moving forward very very important
to have these check-ins on a regular
basis
I want to be super clear about this I
touched on it briefly with that example
of the bike rack in in Rotterdam in the
Netherlands but um if you're going to
plan your work this way and communicate
this way it explicitly requires your
teams to do product Discovery to do
research to do experimentation right
because what you're committing to is
behavior change not features and so it's
up to you and your team
to figure out the best combination of
code and copy and design and business
model and value proposition
Etc that's going to drive that behavior
change and you're going to be wrong
right some of the time and so we need to
learn how to do product Discovery how to
do experimentation we need to make the
time for it in our backlogs
we need to make it a transparent
activity and then build that into our
planning into our work because
inevitably it's going to affect the work
in our backlogs
now
this is going to face some obstacles
inside your organizations there's no
doubt about it your colleagues are going
to have a tough time with this and
certainly your stakeholders and your
managers are going to have a tough time
with this as well
and so the last thing I want to talk
about is some of those challenges and
what you can do to mitigate some of them
right
um one of the interesting things is that
there will be pushback and anxiety
anxiety because there's a whole layer of
middle managers who manage the teams
that we work on that are used to telling
us what to do right go build this make
it blue be done by Friday right that's
my job my job is to tell my team what to
do it's a lot of folks in those
positions who believe that that is their
job
when we manage the outcomes right the
features emerge from the discovery work
and the delivery work that we do on a
quarterly basis
and so what happens is
that this layer of middle management
gets really anxious
because what we've done is we've taken
away a key management task from these
middle managers right we've taken away
the ability to tell people what to do
and they get scared they get scared
because if I don't tell people what to
do then what's my job right because
there's a lot of folks who believe that
that's the defining quality of their
management position is to tell people
what to do
so for this to succeed our middle
managers need to realize that their job
is changing as well it's not telling
people what to do it's to help the teams
Define
and clarify the strategy right what's
the objective that we're working on to
make sure everybody's clear and
understanded
it's the management it's Management's
job to set guard rails and scope we are
focusing on the mobile channel right so
we're going to focus on mobile only not
desktop mobile right we're going to set
those guardrails and the scope to keep
the team focused
if the evidence that comes back from the
experimentation and the learning is
unclear and it often is management can
help make key decisions we're going to
go in this direction instead of that
direction
Management's job is to remove obstacles
to allow this kind of work to take place
the discovery the research the pivoting
the learning the agility they need to
figure out how to help the teams be
successful to remove those obstacles and
ultimately to facilitate their success
to provide them with the tools and the
access and the budgets that they need to
do the work that they need to do that is
the job of middle management certainly
and stakeholders on a team that is
managing to outcomes rather than just
telling the team what to build or what
to do
now there's a flip side to this
conversation right because those middle
managers well they have bosses as well
and those bosses are going to ask them
well what's your team doing what are
they up to what are they working on and
it's terrifying for those middle
managers to not have that answer right
particularly if there's a lot of flux in
the backlog we're still doing a lot of
learning if if you know if my boss comes
to me and says hey Jeff what's your team
working on you know I don't know it's
not a good answer right we've got to
provide a real answer and so for this to
be successful we can't just make a
demand on our managers to work
differently we as the people on the
teams need to step up
and work differently to make our bosses
successful so they leave us alone and
they can communicate clearly with their
bosses our job
as as members of teams who want to
manage to outcomes we want to work
towards outcomes is to build radical
transparency into the way that we work
right how do we make sure that everybody
knows what we're working on what we're
trying what we've experimented what
we've learned what we've killed what
we've pivoted what we've changed how do
we provide access to that on an ongoing
basis how do we make sure that that is
visible and transparent to everyone
right how do we over communicate right
it's a good question we want to over
communicate to our leaders to our
managers so that they have a clear sense
at all times about what's happening on
the team I used to do this with a weekly
email right you could do it with a
check-in you could do with an email you
can do it with a slack Channel with a
Wiki page whatever right there's a
million ways to do this but the idea is
that we are constantly communicating
what we're working on what we're
learning what decisions we're making
right what's being shipped how we're
tracking towards our outcomes Etc
every decision that we make as a team
needs to be backed up with data if we're
going to ask for the ability to do
product Discovery to collect data we
need to use that data to support our
decisions so if we're going to
communicate to our bosses hey we're not
working on this hypothesis anymore and
we've added the second one it's because
the data that we've collected tells us
that this is a better way to go
right every time that we have a
conversation with our bosses we want to
reinforce that our key results that our
outcomes are the goal right they'll say
well I want you to build this okay okay
boss that's terrific how does this thing
that you've got uh that you saw the
competitors have how does that help us
achieve the outcomes that we're
targeting how do you think okay let's
talk about that because the key goal is
not to ship the feature is to change the
behavior right boss
and then of course be very very
consistent with your check-ins right
check in with your leadership after
every short cycle and again this is all
about transparency and over
Communications reduce if you reduce that
anxiety in that middle management layer
the odds of the succeeding increase
exponentially right because they're part
of the process they understand
everything
the other pushback you'll get regularly
is from sales right sales will always
say look how can I like it if if the
features are in flux what am I selling
how do I know what to sell right if you
can't commit to a feature by a date for
me I can't do my job right does that
sound familiar from sales right and so
we have to work with our sales team
again we want to be transparent with
them we want them to know what's
happening why it's happening but the
goal with sales is to convince them that
that they need to sell the benefit
not the feature right so it's not
48 megapixel camera it's amazingly
realistic video to see the new baby from
across the country or across the world
right we want to speak in outcomes help
sales speaking outcomes we're going to
help you increase retention by 50 we're
going to make sure that your data
Integrity levels go up by 90 percent
right we're going to reduce the number
of errors in your mortgage applications
by 57 right this is going to help you
achieve this financial result because
those outcomes inevitably translate into
Financial benefit for the buyers of our
products and services and so it's a
shift for sales to move away from a
series of features right to to speaking
to outcomes and the financial benefits
of those outcomes
and so to do that we have to include
them in the conversation as well look
this way of working
right outcome-based product planning is
the source of agility right it ensures
that we're paying attention to how well
our work is meeting the needs of our
customers right if we're not changing
their behavior in a positive way
uh we have objective measures for that
and we can adjust our work
to hopefully help them be more
successful
the short Cycles the Sprints that we use
that come out of agile right allow us to
minimize investments in feature ideas
that don't help us achieve our outcomes
right
and in doing so right we're forcing our
teams to go and figure out whether or
not we're actually working on something
that is worth investing in and if it
isn't we can pivot and we can move
quickly and making a course Corrections
based on evidence is agility right it is
evidence-based decision making rather
than opinion or job title or salary
based
decision making right and most
importantly outcome-based product
planning helps us stop lying to
ourselves and our bosses and our clients
and really focus on the features and the
solutions that are going to make
everybody ultimately much more
successful
and so with that I want to say thank you
for listening I hope you found that